So let's look at these from the top down.
First, if P equals NP would that mean that every computational
problem could be solved in polynomial time?
Well, no, actually it wouldn't.
First of all, there are problems that simply can't be solved it turns out,
which we'll get to later in the course.
But even if we restrict ourselves to problems
that can actually be solved by a computer,
there are still problems that would not be solvable in polynomial time.
In fact, we mentioned an example of this in an earlier assignment
where if you wanted to print out all the sub lists of list,
then necessarily that means that it will
execute in exponential time not polynomial time because
you have to print out every single possible sub list,
and that's a case where the if better construction doesn't actually help you out,
so this is not the case.
However, the next one is true.
If P were not equal to NP and we proved this,
then that would mean that no
NP-complete problems could be solved in polynomial time.
That's in fact part of the definition of P not equal to NP.
And for the next one, this is also actually true.
This is a little tricky and somewhat subjective depending on
what you mean by easier here,
but it's certainly the case that despite NP-complete problems all being
in some sense as hard as each other,
we might care about a certain subset of instances of a problem
that for whatever reason are easier to solve in practice
than another problem might be,
and that really depends on what in practice you are concerned about
and which instances of a problem that tend to come up in practice.
And for the fourth one, this is not true.
The ability to solve some instances of an NP-complete problem
does not imply that P equals NP.
For example, you can find the clique or a clique
or a minimum vertex cover too
of an empty graph relatively easily.
It's, well, nothing because the empty graph has no vertices and no edges.
That's an example of an instance that you can
quite possibly always solve
or you should always be able to solve very quickly,
but that doesn't mean that you can solve all instances.
And for P equals NP,
we really have to concern ourselves with
every single possible instance of a problem,
and that's really where NP becomes quite complicated.
And finally, showing a problem is NP-complete
means it can't be solved in polynomial time.
Well, no. In order to do this,
we would actually have to show that NP is not NP
or rather P does not equal NP.
That's really the problem we're talking about here in not so many word.
So just being NP-complete isn't enough.
We also have to prove that P does not equal NP.